how are you doing really
oh
[Music]
uh how are you really doing oh I know
deep question right off the bed I'm
actually doing better now I'm in the
healing process so I feel like up on the
up and up basically how are you really
doing
um I'm doing better like same with the
healing process like I think everyone
went through it after covid for sure can
you even imagine what it would be like
if copen wasn't a thing do you think you
would have this much bro no no
absolutely not I'm uh like it's so
it's so weird to say I've honestly kind
of thankful for going yeah oh how I'm
really doing I'm actually doing like
really really well like I I've not been
doing really well most of my life but
I'm doing really really well now oh
that's actually really good to hear
right I go to NYU well I go to school
with um Stella Adler I think it's like a
couple of my teachers teach but oh
some of my teachers taught our teachers
at in I mean NYU Jesus Christ I can't I
can't talk ever I'm like the worst me
too but that's ADHD for me right brain
too fast sentence hard oh yeah no and
like I'm smart but I can't communicate
that like yeah like whatever comes out
of my mouth and whatever's in my head is
like completely different it's just
backwards well it's backwards thinking
and talk it's just silly yeah it's like
it's like if I asked a five-year-old to
like like be my typewriter and then yeah
they you're good like you're getting
across the message general idea but like
in much too long a time and with too
many likes in between and that's what I
feel when I like order food I'm like oh
so this is that so I see this and that
okay so and then like and yeah that's
what I sound like
and they're like yeah and I'm like you
know what actually it's fine just I'll
have the you know what this and you
point to it you know what I'll just get
in water just yeah that'll be fine do
you guys have this one actually you know
what I'll just pay you and I'll go I'm
good I'm fine I promise
what is something that you don't want to
admit
oh my gosh uh my love and discipline for
ballet and dance has kind of gone down
my entire life I've always said I want
to be a dancer it's what I want to do
it's what I love it's my passion and I
feel like it's almost become like a
habit of saying that all I have like
left is me just saying that I love it
and not like actually feeling it if that
makes any sense yeah
so I feel like I'm just like trying to
like make myself believe that I love it
basically
yeah I feel like that's I have 100 been
there and I have 100 been there at
your age when I was your age which I've
never said to someone which is so weird
but when I when I was your age I felt
the same exact thing I was coming out of
high school and I was looking at what I
was Finding was that I was doing a lot
of comparing myself to a lot a lot of
people I was feeling uninspired because
I didn't I was young and I really hadn't
experienced a lot comparison is the
thief of joy and I I've learned that
in those years and still learn it now
and like
as a as a fellow creative I think that
like you can't expect to be perfect and
on your game all the time because we're
human like of course you've gotta you
know you gotta allow yourself to have
those moments of like okay I may not I
may not
feel like the fire burning passion like
I like I did once before but it doesn't
mean it's never gonna happen again yeah
you could you can feel the fire from
anything it could hit you one day like
you never expected it you're right
you're right something I don't want to
admit
that I want to be in a relationship oh
and it's really corny like
I I love love I love like when you said
like I have a boyfriend I literally like
smiled like a stupid little kid I was
like that's so cute and like I've tried
to be less Petty about it because I used
to be like no I want it and I don't have
it and like a baby right yeah yeah but
like
I love when people are in love I love
that I eat that [ __ ] up who do you need
to forgive and why
wow okay
I'm like nobody boo
um
even I'm thinking I'm like what do I
need to forgive I mean [ __ ] I don't need
to forgive that person what the [ __ ]
right that's what I'm saying I'm like
I've already forgived enough people in
like you know I feel like I spend my
whole life forgiving people and now I'm
realizing that I was wrong the whole
time so how about you
oh
probably
my family
just like
instead of
holding in these feelings
that I've had like instead of like
causing a scene I've just held it in so
like it's on me kind of and I need to
like
I
forgive my family for things that I've
just not communicated to them yeah I get
that his heart is don't you ever feel
like it's so hard to communicate to the
people closest to you absolutely like I
can tell people I work with I'm like you
know like
bruh it's so annoying how you did that
but like anyone in my family of like oh
they're gonna hate me for the rest of my
life if I bring up the fact that they
didn't wash the dishes last week
or something like small yeah do you do
you wonder why that is sometimes
yeah do you have any theories
um I think it's because they have an
interpretation of you since you were so
small and it's hard to break out of
being like Oh I'm your innocent
little little uh girl and
you always known me and you're gonna
just I can always disappoint you or
something
that's it that's literally it yeah wait
how did you just put that into words
that was beautiful eloquent thanks
wow uh what's your biggest insecurity
um
I feel like I'm actually pretty secure
with myself and most things
um love it I don't usually care what
people think about me until it's like
like someone you're romantically with
which is weird to say because it's such
like an important thing like to me I
said that
I just feel like I don't know
it's yeah I told it's like I'm talking
to myself right now like that's exactly
how I feel like it's that feeling of
like I put so many things on a pedestal
in my life and love is one of them like
romantic relationships so like when yeah
I I just like I totally get that yeah
yeah what is your biggest insecurity
um my lack of assertiveness
I I've learned this year to be way more
assertive and it's become so helpful in
my life but like leaving situations much
sooner than I would have like years ago
like yeah like I've like been in
relationships with exes that like I I
should not have been in relationships
with them for that long to a point where
like one of my exes broke up with me and
they're like I know you want to break up
with me so I'm just going to do it for
you and I was like oh I was like oh
thank God but I still cried obviously
after but I'm getting there you know
everyone has the insecurities and like
what are you gonna do you gotta keep
going
yeah I agree because the security what's
yours then
I think like me me not being able to get
my like what I want to stay out to the
best of my ability with dyslexia it's
like your brain processes things
at a slower Pace because it's it's not
like you're not dumb at all it's just
take it's like it's a very inefficient
like way of processing things or like
the route with your like information is
like gone throughout your brain like
so I sometimes feel like I'm just not
getting to the point and I'm talking too
much even though like I know that I'm
smart and people know that I'm smart but
I can't like articulate what I want to
say correctly and not just with that but
with people like
you know when I don't want when I wanna
when I really focus on what I want to
say
um it doesn't come out what if it's like
passive talking then maybe I find myself
like more comfortable and like easier to
like say what I want to say but I'm
really trying and I'm feeling like
anxious and like really trying to make
sure I don't like get misunderstood I
find that like it does happen and like
it makes me feel awful really I just
like
I just feel like I just feel like an
awful like I just feel like I'm dumb but
like even like I know I'm not I just
like I'm wasting people's time and I'm
like annoying so yeah I felt that one I
hear you're loud and clear you're loud
and clear bro what's something that
scares you about yourself I'm scared of
how much how onside I am to like talk
about
um what's on my mind
okay what do you mean like I can say
what's on my mind and no one has to even
ask me I'm way too open that's I guess
that's mostly what it is I'm way too but
what about that's scary too
um makes people more susceptible to hurt
me
so because the more open and honest you
are the more people see you and it's
like it can attract some bad people as
well very true you just have a lot of
love to give yeah so how about you I'm
very trusting
it has gotten me into a lot of bad
situations which I feel is like in the
same field as being too open
um yeah it does make people able to like
take advantage of you a little more and
stuff yeah but I guess
it's a good thing to be open to because
there's a lot of good people in my life
that get attracted from it exactly can't
meet good people without putting
yourself out there a little maybe
meeting some bad I mean we're doing this
right now so yeah we're really putting
ourselves out here we are we're killing
it if you knew no one at this park can
see you right now what would you do
really funny my first thought was to
just like dance around like a total fool
flail and like run yeah like to skip why
are we not like yeah like we should why
did we get rid of skipping exactly I
think adults should be skipping like the
serotonin would be so much higher in our
society if we all just started and we'd
get everywhere faster too right bring
back something
oh my God just skip the one
down oh my God should we skip together
yeah like that's so funny
should I should I stand up
okay so no headphones
[Music]
so wait can we look at each other oh
you're so pretty
can I give you a hug oh my god of course
of course so nice to meet you it's okay
do you wanna hold hands okay
yeah let's just let's just go let's go
for it yeah one two three
[Music]
the next question is why do we think we
met today
um I feel like for me maybe because I'm
new here and I
like don't know anyone like at all
really
so
um I guess like I know someone now yeah
oh that's really sweet yeah it's funny
you could know a friend for so long and
have these questions not
you can you would never know the answers
to these questions yeah like you would
never ask your friends these questions
like randomly one day so I think like
when you do it with a stranger it's like
oh my God like you you realize that like
there are people and you love who
haven't even been who haven't even known
the answers to these questions yeah you
know yeah yeah yeah
it was so fun
I really like how open you were to doing
this that's really cool I enjoyed this I
enjoyed meeting you me too I really
enjoyed talking to you you're great last
question
what do you think we met
I think we met so we could become
friends oh yeah
I love about sentiment
yay why do you think we met
um I think we met just to see
just to like reflect on ourselves yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
I think we needed that for some reason
no way today yeah I feel like
the way you word things really did help
which is which is great thank you yeah
thank you as well
oh we're standing up okay
oh
yes and slay hi are you like a hug
person yes ma'am hi Hi how are you I'm
doing pretty good where's okay now I see
the blue or the yeah I like the mullet
that's for some reason expected it to be
curly I like your I like your fit thank
you I was trying to like do a classified
straight man spin like that's what I'm
doing I feel I'm feeling a little femi
I'm gonna do a little
I'm gonna do that
my mom said the dress of like someone's
like gay Uncle which I'm like that's
definitely true that's what I'm going
that's what I want to be right I'm
trying to be someone's gay uncle
hello
here so we can just
follow each other
[Music]